firstly because it's up first because
it's shorter I what I have a look at
this now what I love about and they
aren't the reason why are sure to
continue is because there's so much I
would argue the hardest part that is
right about this because what are four
tiles again what is it core time if the
things on the singing with the it's like
it's in the leniency okay all right so
if you recall if you're a whole bunch of
scores like that we know what the media
is the meaning is whatever it is that
provides the scores in half right and
quartiles are doesn't up to bring it
again as the name suggests you're
dividing into two sections you're
dividing into four right so what you're
looking for is on the median and then
you find them in between of the reasons
right so you do get these one two three
numbers this is one of things you
confuse me other cool tiles what one is
three of them is because it took lessons
/ so that's right secondly how many gold
on there are eight scores which means
each of the sections that are going to
divide up into it like like this it's as
if there are eight scores in total
should have to score to score two tours
& tues gone okay so you can see how this
device here is to achieve this buggy
that's all looking good you've also
noticed because the survey lines they
don't fall on a school they fall between
scores do you notice that so therefore
you've actually got to do something
extra to find these this 11 where does
that come from can you see where it's
come from it's a it's for an 80 right
which should be added here 22 and then
you divide by two because you want the
average of those two and that sure
enough gives you 11 okay now that's also
correct you have to do that don't want
to work to find quartile there's only
one thing that's missing and it's an
easy thing what is it we just need to
reorder it that's the only thing and we
just need to do that from the get-go
okay so can someone told me devil ray
auditors
what is the order 14 yep 11 yep pretty
really cool okay so once you got the
scores in odd on you can take the same
process and is exactly right so it's the
future and you take the average which is
by the hot yes so that's the first
quartile you take warm out to these
people and so the average is perfect
yeah and then you take these two scores
and the average will be 19 and a half
right so what we have is numbers were
five of them are Jessie and 19 and thank
you these are the quartiles okay lower
quartile the median and the capital so
the present is exactly right there's
just one step it's a little one I like
using anyone that was just ripped out so
as I review that some pity what do you
think okay search then comes the next in
function which is what's going wrong
okay because the water working he was
very helpful sweet this obsessive but
I'm what's going on now before it's a
question please basically use different
like this strategy yeah like a group you
wanna hit up what's it call you okay so
you can see very helpfully click away so
the point is killing my goodness
goodness cottage cheese because the way
he helped me tells us what it's doing we
know about the darkness looks like a so
I just say whichever method you used to
simultaneous equations one of the first
thing you got to do is give your
equation some mates okay
on that and then we start to work with
this now have a look just at this one
you agree with this line x equals a
profile were you happy with that cool I
do is not what you doing issues changing
the subject so that you can continue but
so far so good okay then we get to hear
all right so we're going into equation
one in sky has the substitutions on oh
yes again hopefully not skip any steps
you can see the direct substitution in
there that's just in place of X there's
a free Rose is too early and at seven so
far so good what's the name of the
process from this way to dislike with a
corner we have expanded right this way
it's factorizing make a factor tree this
way anyways there might well come to me
in 10 seconds are not report um we
respected is that the right vision yeah
cool okay all right from here to here
what's the intention of this okay so
there's actually a couple of things
happening number one is the texture 24
get through to the conference to design
gets it over there come back to the like
terms and secondly there's question of
ice cube as well yes yeah so do we agree
with this light yeah yeah Alex it so
that is this is good yeah so we've gone
pretty far right yeah okay so some
insurance really what is the thing right
now this is what I do this all the time
every bit of it like me doing it if your
company and say in the drive and I just
said you yes my a curator is correct
right then what you learn to do is
attach your understanding whether
something is right or not on whether I
tell you is right or not always pretty
reliable it's reliable except for the
fact that i'm not there at all the time
doesn't count so it's reliable but
absolutely insult i'm so a couple of
guys would come back to here by the way
why was this the choice why this
equation
india because rotted this on my girl
this is three day I don't you bet this
is good I got triaging there's probably
one place slightly better than this
contention where else could i put knew i
could probably put it into you here like
could x is already the subject so i
would have gotten out in the same number
of sailors that maybe people so does the
supposition look good I think yes there
it is what's that double dated yes so
then what's this about what's she doing
it she doesn't what the extra stuff she
wouldn't be X alone she went at the
subject right decision to cast fun and
that's what she's getting in yeah oh
yeah oh my god possibly i'm so a good
one time sure if we went all the way
through let's have a look negative 1 is
brilliant make you want to bring it in
at three take away 5 volts of negative
135 you say yes ah let's see what people
are doing so nice we lost she's lots of
negative one it's my money to mr. happy
yeah but good job precious so I did that
all right
oh I felt like I was doing you're very
wrong did your working with was it yeah
I did not exactly but I think it's
smaller and wife is like really
regretting that you what give me about
making them the third like an idea you
could often body let me start discussion
of all of it just set a bathroom is why
the beginning of Homewood tsoukalos
question we identified that laura has
done it by substitution of course that's
one of the methods that we have what the
other one information is young one now
if we wanted to how would we take the
original to equator than use them if we
wanted to do elimination what would we
do so if you've got to look at okay
which variable can I eliminate hence the
name right I'm either going to get rid
of the exes or I'm going to get rid of
the wires okay now in order to do that I
need the same number of extras in both
equations all the same number why is in
both equations either one is fine just
you got choose ok now if i want to say
number of why have a look see how this
two-year this fun hear what I have to do
is I have multiplied this equation by 5
whatever whatever there we can why then
i have to multiply this equation by 5
plus x 2 i could divide us together me
too because that will be whatever
whatever minus 10 why does that make
sense here we attend liking a minus 10
one day and use Adam and they'll
eliminate hey I could do that if I
wanted to go with the exes instead of
wine or rather fallen to eliminate the
excess driving on what would I do
the second equation right here I just
need to multiply this by three in order
to have it match right so which one will
they choose I would choose to get rid of
the excess because i only have to
multiply one equation not to ok so it's
sort of a matter of is different really
if it says this operation here which is
the substitution work if I've said
equation to multiply it by three 3x
minus 15y equals 24 that called back to
eight instead of this it would have been
fun I think it would have worked out I'm
much the same in terms of its length
sometimes the question even obviously
done better by substitution or
elimination so you just kind of go for
it unless they ask you to do with this
right now any other questions what I'm
don't like and it does like you're
looking for what am I done did I get it
right some of these numbers maybe you're
not being confused 17 that's what we
know about to come up with something
like something with no one ok this is
quite astonishing because you guys know
why don't know if you know me I tend to
make things up like I just stand here
and then I just make them up so it's
somewhat a true since with these is not
like I actually expected Messier like
fractions and read numbers or letters in
possession if it will watch it might
never know